[Music]
so what do you guys do for first dates
like what do you do to impress your
first date that is article here what
it's talking about like the headline
says how to quickly figure out if you
and your date actually have chemistry
and they're suggesting to do this thing
called the FD p.m. which is first date
Power Move oh that's just our FD p.m. we
just slap her around a little bit what
are Power Move our movies like a power
stance yeah so hot tea so hot
create the elocution that you are that's
all of us Steve yeah Dan gonna elocution
is is the popular they're saying it it's
not about exerting your dominance
it's more about like uh like figuring
out like they're the type of person that
they are based on a certain situation
just go far in front of would it be
something like where the guy like opens
the car door for example like that's his
stance I know the first date in so long
so I wouldn't know what guys how many
people don't guys don't do that always
open doors like that would tell me a lot
on the outside I always offer to order
for you so I guess I got an example of
these here it's kind of like ordering a
non-alcoholic drink at a bar and then
you can see how your date reacts to that
and like that shows a lot of character
analysis that you can like I mean mine's
different eyes opposite so like for me
sense of humor is really important I
ordered a drink I would start starting
it with my finger just to see how the
reaction is and if people think I'm
weird I'm like this isn't gonna click
and the girl comes in like I open the
door for myself and then I'll leave it
open so she can come in right after but
right when she gets close like closer
behind
I got to see if they got a good sense of
humor on the Lord on it first days
excuse me vodka soda wine please
thank you and then he's like so tell me
about you yeah and then in then Bart's
like this isn't gonna work the first day
is got to be do we click comedy-wise
second date I'm a gentleman
yeah not the first day it's like
everyone's gonna be the best behavior I
need to figure out if you're real or not
these guys don't really do it the first
day how has this worked out so well for
you that that is the worst idea I've
ever heard I mean first date will just
be a silly man the next day all of a
sudden out of nowhere you had your
complete gentleman date the [ __ ]
button up and some [ __ ] jogger pants
just tucked in like who's ready to party
put your dick up my golf cart with my
horn on it that's what I'm saying
it's a [ __ ] accident Bart get Bart
gets out of a space craft that just
crashed landed and he's like it works
and he's like yeah well here's what you
got to do is like yeah there's no I
don't like the books on these things it
works for me that's like you kind of
aren't doing like a first date part move
where you can see how the other person's
gonna react for you if they match you
can match me cuz they're staying here
like you know for first dates like on
both sides each person is so worried
about like making a good impression that
you're forgetting like wait does this am
I even gonna like this person yeah you
know you're so caught up and making sure
they like you but you forget to realize
like wait do I even like them so more
examples that they use here like for
this one person their voice like the
sound and their voice is really
important and a partner like that's
that's like what is important to them so
they may like vocal cratis occation and
so for this person in the past they
would wait until they meet in person and
then like they would she would be like
oh I kind of don't like your voice
whatever but now now this person in
instead we'll face time a date before
even getting out of the house and be
like oh now I could hear your voice you
sound like [ __ ] new filtering process
another one another example is that
they'll ask a Power Move that's their
date like what like do you go to therapy
and depending on how they respond
whether they do or they do whatever
things are important to them I've heard
someone go that gun yeah yeah kind of
like that I've heard someone go like I
want to know what your political stance
is and I'm like whoa you ask them
they're like yeah that's really
important to me
yeah Thursday I'd like that
I like the spaceship crashing more than
the yeah I saw space for a second it
totally were like it's not important
investor s sure cuz I'm like this other
person said like on the first date I
ordered the messiest juiciest burger on
the menu cuz then for him he's like well
if you can handle me at my ugly estate
in like my most like big date then we're
good people
yeah I always encourage women to eat on
the first day I hate when women come and
we're just gonna have a salad and all
that [ __ ] nerve this way is the things
like let me know what the [ __ ] I'm
working with monetarily right if you
only eat a salad on the first day and
have one drink I'm thinking that I the
second day we're gonna be about the same
my money second day you got a [ __ ]
hunger appetite like you were starving
now it's $150 like [ __ ] that's not what
I brought with me okay I budgeted this
date for $65 with tip because last time
you would eat like a [ __ ] rabbit now
you just finish [ __ ] Avengers and now
you hungry no I don't like that just let
me know when I'm good huh expensive 65
bucks yes Wow I like your dates he's
right though I eat before I go on a date
track one of the [ __ ] movies now not
spending like 50 bucks it oh my god hey
take her to the park man yeah
no no doubt like at this point it's like
you got to get creative with the dates
at this point and now I always encourage
like like don't like movies are horrible
first dates bar the horrible first dates
go somewhere you could talk like it meet
him at coffee man like
but you won't spend more than $15 - you
got tea you don't have to get coffee do
you like sparkling water or something
like that know what I like I like
miniature golf
yes your honor talkin like take your
mind off of it I'm always competitive -
so much in your face [ __ ] she was like
I don't hit on my hit a [ __ ] one of
our first dates where are we Santa
Monica
we're playing the air hockey thing mmm I
love that no it's just like we're just
playing and having a good time and but
both me and our competitive yeah so we
start [ __ ] smacking the [ __ ] up and
then I played seven rounds that we kept
feeding that machine no no but then
after that's how initials won because
they were like we're both bummed about
it [ __ ] yeah that's great putting up a
front like in the beginning how you're
just going like that's the front part
that you're trying to like get
comfortable and you don't even know if
you're really vibing yeah yeah will you
show your true self because they're
saying here like real connection is
nearly impossible without offering
something of yourself up true because
then like how how else are you gonna be
like how do you expect someone else to
be vulnerable and get to know them if
you're not even doing the same but also
put your best foot forward out of
[ __ ] respect this [ __ ] like I ordered
the messies [ __ ] burger nacho cheese
all over it yeah and I put nacho cheese
all over the top of the bun no put your
plates pretty manipulate out of [ __ ]
respect right - no it's a move you're
making a move week about this [ __ ]
you're not just ordering something that
you wanted to eat you're doing it for a
move right no but what if that is
something that what they would normally
eat that's fine but that's not what
they're not they're doing it to get a
reaction from people so they can figure
who they are like which is very
manipulative if you gotta eat a burger
like it's just okay yeah my taking my
burger what if I just sparked right now
would you still love me you know
probably my I haven't smash yet but it's
yeah there's definitely a fine line
between it being manipulative and then
just really just be like showing your
true self and being real that's what
matters like it feel like like a sloppy
joe burger and you just eat it normally
that's cool but this person sounds like
they take it apart do you still love I
don't use I wouldn't even be freaked out
by it
I would be more upset like did you
really just waste at this burger it like
you just wasted 17 dollars i think you
[ __ ] up the date by trying to impress
people like you're constantly trying to
win approval so you're self-conscious
you're like do they like me once you
stop giving a [ __ ] about all that [ __ ]
it actually increases your chance it's
the same [ __ ] as a pickup culture and
how will that follow my dude thing all
kinds of stupid [ __ ] that the squirrel
you don't I mean yeah so it's like
there's I make this move and like oh
yeah tell her like not compliment so she
wants to like earn your same exact you
can translate it that way I but I could
also get behind what they're trying to
say too cuz like for example for me
because I was trying to think to like
what would be my version of this and I
think if like if I would be on a first
date and I get to pick what we do
because sometimes you know I like the
guy just be like okay you take me you do
it but if I had to pick I would want to
build IKEA furniture together that's
tough because I'm trying to think like
what's the worst quality in me I'm
really controlling with little things so
I'm like that would be a good test like
can we joke I'd be bored swap by some
ham
we made it through so I think we're
gonna get keys you can do just two so
simple it and take it back huh would you
buy something just to put it together
then disassembly then take it back
hey it's an investment on her life oh no
Jim was single she just had a bunch I
just heard a [ __ ] Studios like yeah
which one tonight I want arrested or
Casey's coming in he's like hey let's
throw me this half-built bookcase and
she's like let's leave it for a little
bit I'm still getting over that's a good
that's a good day today if you actually
need something well maybe I can't just
be rebuilding wine we'd take wine in and
and IKEA furniture and food or something
lobby yeah and then also music I feel
like cuz I'm really big on music so like
while we're doing that like we both like
if we say we're gonna do this I'm like I
would come with a playlist hey I want
that hip hop on me that's not what I
would say it almost turned hip-hop this
now without saying it all just cover to
play this I want to see what your date
before YouTube right yeah absolutely
let me check his work see what you're
bringing to the table absolutely what we
sambar something you saw that did no
other said what if she comes to that
tambourine
that's not useless at all no playlist
though I think couple to play with but
you said music and she's like here's the
thing if she came and she could shake
the [ __ ] out of the tambourine and she
can sing at the same time and I'm with
it but like at Emory only has so much
like reigns it's like you can't like
this oh yeah I need ten songs which are
you ready to do ten songs with a
tambourine
what is your bust I like this
I would have had Frances you came in to
play the recorder and said you're really
playing this long I would be legit
impressed is that what your dream woman
does naked yeah and I'm the flute okay I
could get behind this power mode stuff
if it's the honest part like there's
this weird quirk about you but you're
honest enough you're not trying to
overplay it just to see people vibe I
can get behind it but if you're like
we're going way above and beyond I'm
just gonna keep farting during this
whole dinner do you like me now that's
that's in the doors thing right if
that's not really who you are you're
gonna get found out eventually like so
don't you know mm yeah I do think you
should put your best foot forward though
and I do think she could talk doors for
chicks because [ __ ] doors are dirty
and it's out of respect not because they
can't open doors yeah nothing close
right behind you so they can get
[Music]